I have just been sucked into this whole
world and I'm enthralled and because I
started out as a TV writer I just got
this compulsion I want to meet the
writer behind all this I want to meet
the mind that created all this so you
were very nice to come people get to see
you people see your name but they don't
see you well this just as well I think
no no no that's a good thing first of
all so much to talk about the idea for
Breaking Bad I remembered when I first
heard the idea of a chemistry teacher in
high school getting sick and he starts
making meth to to just pay the bills and
then it leads one thing I thought that
when I just heard the idea I thought
that's a great idea how did you get that
idea I was talking to a buddy of mine
named Thompson Alice was one of my
writers now guy went to NYU film school
with many many many years ago and he and
I both been writers on The X Files at
this point in time we were a couple
years out from doing that show were you
unemployed at the time very much
unemployed and we were very much hoping
that some other job was coming our way
but nothing writing wise was forthcoming
so we're talking about should we you
know go work at H&R Block should we dig
ditches and what else are we fit for
yeah because digging ditches
you know that's my back is not as strong
as it used to be I don't think I could
do that
right right dig ditches or create a
genius TV show but he was we were
talking on the phone but moaning are our
unemployment or and he had mentioned an
article you read in the New York Times
in which some guy had put a meth lab in
the back of an RV and was driving around
making a cooking meth much I guess I'm
sort of a really demented ice cream
truck I suppose and very popular oh yeah
wait-wait-wait outsells the ice-cream
truck yeah
this is fine but you gotta check out and
they you know when he meant she said
maybe we should do that and and as suzie
mentioned that it was the darkness
saying this this idea for this character
who would do such a thing
became of great interest to me and i and
i wanted to pursue that idea and and you
know i didn't have a name for this
character yet i certainly didn't have a
name for the show but lo and behold this
this idea kind of sprung into my head
the the interest in such a character
sprung into my head and you know i
appreciate what you say about the show
being a great idea it seems to me in
hindsight a terrible idea for a TV show
with a fifty year old guy dying a cancer
cooking crystal meth i I am amazed to
this day well I'm glad it's not a
multi-camera sitcom with an audience
it's not the next Cosby Show but still
III think you're right there when you
hear oaep about a lot of classic
television shows you someone could tell
you the idea you could say that's
terrible yeah but but also if it's
executed correctly it's brilliant I'm
curious about something you seem like
such a nice mild-mannered fellow this
world you've created is so violent I
think some of the most dramatic and
really breathtaking violence that I've
seen on television has been on Breaking
Bad you don't stomach violence very well
yourself do you well the real thing or
you know just even seeing it I'm going
to beat you now and we're going to find
out but when you're watching when you're
watching a movie and there's intense
violence I've heard that you have
trouble with I have been known to to
faint blood sugar I don't know what it
is that
yeah and in the damnedest movies to you
know not not the one he's made you fate
Vincent and Theo the story of Vincent
van Gogh's during 1000 that one that was
a Disney animated movie you see because
I'm thinking of some of the scenes
you've created the you know there's
there's a classic scene of a shootout in
a supermarket parking lot or I think was
a Walmart parking lot and I'm a bit but
just the some of the scenes are so
powerful and but you yourself you're not
comfortable with it no and it did it on
the surface it seems very
counterintuitive that I would would you
know that that kind of stuff would
affect me in the end we'd we'd my
wonderful writers and I'm a six
excellent writers and I would write that
kind of stuff but it seems to me that
you write the things that excite you or
horrify you and and so when you think
about it in those terms it kind of makes
sense and in a way you need to deal with
the stuff that you're the most
uncomfortable with to create something
powerful yeah maybe maybe it's something
like that I don't know it's a therapy
session what if by talking to you I ruin
this genius formulas of it that way and
I have no more ideas